how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we know a lot about phase four of the
MCU the entire phase four slate has been
revealed we got our first phase four
trailer with the release of the first
black widow trailer plus even more
footage for Black Widow at CC XP that
Kevin Feige showed not to mention some
footage shown at CC XP as well of the
Eternals plus Kevin feige's comments on
the internals as well
tons of leaked photos for the one
division series and the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series as well and of
course you can't forget the random plot
leaks that come out either but we don't
really know much about phase 5 a few
movies have been confirmed but that's
all we really have but it seems like
brie Larson Captain Marvel herself could
be giving us a little bit of a clue as
what movie's going to be coming in phase
5 obviously it's going to involve
Captain Marvel but it may not be a
Captain Marvel 2 movie instead it could
involve Captain Marvel in another movie
this is something that has actually been
talked about for a pretty long time now
Captain Marvel appearing in another
movie or somebody else appearing in
Captain Marvel - mainly because Captain
Marvel - will most likely be Secret
Invasion
and people have reported when we can
expect the next Captain Marvel movie and
that we could probably expect Peter
Parker to be in the movie as well if it
is Secret Invasion and this report of
Captain Marvel 2 being Secret Invasion
and if it is Secret Invasion spider-man
is going to be a part of it in a
crossover film by a few different
credible people in the industry one of
which is Daniel RPK and now it seems
like a lot of people are thinking that
brie Larson has just teased a team-up
with either her and spider-man or
Captain Marvel and black panther these
would be two crazy team ups and kind of
be unexpected but let's break down what
could possibly be coming quick reminder
to subscribe when notifications turn on
I like the video and leave a comment so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 so here's
the photo that brie Larson posted a few
days ago now it's a photo from the set
of Avengers in game of course and at
first glance nobody thought that it
really meant anything however the
argument here is that brie posting this
to Instagram is very out of the norm and
different than what she usually posts
but then we had a leaked online that
said spider-man is going to be teaming
up with
captain marvel in a crossover film now
based off of everything that we've heard
from Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios about the future of the MCU and
the future of the Avengers this isn't
too big of a surprise and now with this
photo that brie posted to her Instagram
of her and Tom Hollen and Chadwick
Boseman some people are thinking that
this leak could be true and that she is
actually teasing it in this photo
teasing Captain Marvel - Secret Invasion
and possibly teasing a team-up with
spider-man and possibly black panther
although we have had no reports that
that is in the works because we haven't
really actually heard anything about
Captain Marvel - and we haven't heard
anything about spider-man's crossover
movie that is said to be in the deal
that Sony had Disney worked out but we
know that a Captain Marvel - is coming
because Kevin Feige confirmed this at
San Diego comic-con and we know that
Disney Sony spider-man deal was for
another solo film and a crossover film
but based off of what Kevin Feige and
executive producer Trent Randolph said
it doesn't seem like we're going to be
getting a big Avengers film anytime soon
at least not in phase 5 so what could
this crossover film be well it could be
with Captain Marvel and I'll tell you
why this actually kind of works for the
MCU
because if brie Larson is teasing
something then there's really only a few
things that it could be and a crossover
film with spider-man could be one of
them it's been stated and kind of known
for a long time that Captain Marvel and
Peter Parker / spider-man are going to
be the ones who lead the Avengers moving
forward in the MCU that's why people
were really really worried when the sony
disney spider-man deal sort of fell
through at first because they thought
that Captain Marvel is now going to be
the sole leader of the avengers moving
forward and people didn't really like
that because yes she is really really
powerful but she's new however
spider-man is supposed to step up and
kind of take on the mantle of Iron Man
and he was supposed to do this alongside
of Captain Marvel I've stated many times
that the MCU moving forward is supposed
to be split a grounded future and a
cosmic future meaning we'll have the
heroes and villains and all of their
story arts that take place on earth
the heroes and villains and their story
arts that take place in space this has
pretty much been known for some time now
and it was supposed to be Peter Parker
who leads the ground team on earth and
it's supposed to be Captain Marvel who
leads the cosmic team and this is how
the original Avengers kind of worked as
well they had two leaders Captain
America and Iron Man yes a lot of people
will say that Captain America was the
leader of the Avengers and yes that's
true but Tony was definitely a leader as
well in fact that's why we had Captain
America Civil War because there was two
leaders of the Avengers Captain America
and Iron Man and they disagreed then
half of the Avengers followed one leader
who they thought was the leader and who
they thought was right and the other
half followed the other one so moving
forward it would make sense that the
Avengers would have two leaders one that
would lead in space and one that would
lead on earth
so a Captain Marvel spider-man crossover
film would make sense now spider-man
solo film is probably going to come out
before Captain Marvel 2 comes out
considering that nothing really at all
has been said about Captain Marvel 2 and
there's no doubt that Captain Marvel
isn't going to return to Earth and
Captain Marvel - yes you will probably
explore space a little bit but she'll
definitely return to Earth especially
because as we saw in Avengers in game
she is very involved and she is part of
the team and unfortunately since some
big members of the team are gone
Iron Man Captain America and Black Widow
she kind of has to step up now
not to mention fury was kind of in
charge of the Avengers he's the one that
brought them all together with the
Avengers initiative Fury and Captain
Marvel are really close we saw them get
really close in Captain Marvel and we
saw Carol Danvers cry when she saw a
picture of Fury confirming that he was
dusted in Avengers end game so the next
time there's a pretty big threat that an
Avengers team is needed fury will most
likely call her in and it seems like a
Secret Invasion is probably coming and
spider-man is already a little bit
connected to it at least he has actually
been involved with it and spider-man far
from home the Nick Fury and Maria Hill
that Peter Parker was speaking to the
entire time of the movie was actually
Talos and his wife and Peter Parker had
absolutely no idea that's one of the
powers of the scroll when they
shape-shift they also take on the
memories and personalities of the people
that they shape-shift into and yes so
far the scroll that we have been
introduced to are
which was a really big twist on Marvel
and Disney's behalf because the scroll
have always been bad however just
because the ones that we've been
introduced to our good does not mean
that they are all good
just like with any population there are
going to be good people and there are
going to be bad people and Marvel
probably wouldn't miss out on doing a
Captain Marvel secret invasion story
Secret Invasion
is a huge story and not to mention
there's also a lot of opportunity to
bring other Avengers into this movie not
necessarily as themselves but as Scroll
in disguise playing the Avengers so
Captain Marvel 2 could actually end up
being a big crossover event in a type of
way and this would probably make the
movie a big success having all of these
different heroes in it but let's go back
to the reports that say spider-man is
going to be in the next Captain Marvel
film for a secret invasion according to
some rumors it's been said that Tom
Hollands Peter Parker and spider-man are
going to be added to Captain Marvel 2 to
sort of lighten up the film and add some
much-needed humor it has also been
rumored that Tom Hollands Peter Parker
if he is in Secret Invasion is going to
have a big crush on Carol Danvers
however Carol will not be about that not
to mention there's a huge age difference
as well but again if they go this story
route it's to lighten up Captain Marvel
too because despite its huge success
Captain Marvel has been getting a little
bit of backlash a lot of fans weren't
really that excited that she was so Opie
in Avengers endgame she kind of just
showed up at the end to save the day and
pretty easily overpowered Thanos so
rumor has it that another reason for
putting Peter Parker in Captain Marvel 2
is to make the film more likable that of
course is just a rumor for now Captain
Marvel 1 was a huge success and the
Secret Invasion line is a pretty
interesting story
you basically have scroll disguised as
all of these different superheroes that
we know and we love and it gets to the
point where even the heroes don't know
who their allies are and who are scroll
in disguise and again we've kind of
already saw this in spider-man far from
home Tom Holland did not know that Nick
Fury and Maria Hill were actually Tallis
and his wife but as for right now it
seems like the two people that the real
Nick Fury would be close with and in
contact with would be Carol Danvers and
Peter Parker Carol Danvers obviously
with a relationship they built in the
first Captain Marvel movie and Pete
Parker given the fact that he kind of
just saved the world from Mysterio and
he did it thinking he was under the
direction of Nick Fury which he actually
was because Nick Fury was the one that
issued the order to tell us to have him
as Nick Fury tell spider-man to
investigate the elementals so it really
was under the direction of Nick Fury
Nick Fury personally wanted spider-man
so if the Secret Invasion does happen
Nick Fury is most likely to call upon
Peter Parker and of course Carol Danvers
now of course we've had reports about
Secret Invasion and about spider-man
appearing in Secret Invasion which is
why it's believed that brie Larson in
this photo is actually teasing that
however Black Panthers in this photo as
well and some people are thinking that
Black Panther could be involved in
Secret Invasion with Peter Parker and
that isn't a too far-fetched idea Black
Panther is an Avenger now it's because
of Black Panther and Wakanda that the
Avengers really had a chance against
Thanos in his army and that goes for
infinity war and endgame so it wouldn't
be too much to think that the Avengers
could call upon Black Panther in Wakanda
once again to help with the Skrull
secret invasion or as I mentioned before
some of the scroll could shape-shift
into black panther it's something that
happened in the comics and if we really
are getting a Secret Invasion something
that will most likely happen in the
Secret Invasion and I do like the idea
of Marvel doing a Secret Invasion where
a bunch of scroll shape-shift into
Avengers and nobody really knows who's
who it would be really interesting and
there could be a ton of plot twists but
let me know what you think about this
would you like spider-man to be in
Captain Marvel 2 for Secret Invasion and
if that happens would you like Black
Panther to be in the movie as well and
would you like to see the scroll turn
into all these other different Avengers
do you think brie Larson is teasing
Secret Invasion let me know what you
think in the comments down below also
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 the winner
will get to choose and I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers click the link down
below for your chance to win and
Infinity Gauntlet and don't forget to
use code cosmic at G fuel comm for 30%
off G fuel as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
you